[Music]
Osuna Roboto qua not Antonov a shoe not
even tactic restored the reason he no
believe over their national mapper multi
on me let me see a test article Olivier
a cantata Donato carnotaur
era commission what River so lucky
you're able to keep the bellavita
the island of you deli parts of La
Maddalena National Park sits on the
northern coast of Sardinia it's
considered to be one of the most
beautiful islands in the Mediterranean
Sea only accessible by boat
Maurer morandi whose sole inhabitant
first arrived here 29 years ago and he
never left sooner Roberto Park as well
named his animal of superior hypocrisy
stable dude LD crostata Kucera prima the
fabulous ananda will start to hopefully
Fortuna and he'll freeze impossible to
store the presidentís but that and
nonsense you know the Bellas said of an
unassisted one they'll be Newton a la
mierda Mora queen on arrival in electric
aperture on guitar to deepen le photo
voltages - Tanya : the Peloquin give an
opportunity so no four cylinders the
open consumers in a western movie Natale
a critical to periodical warm regard and
Martha molto general diverse University
started in van develop a new business
unit plug amatis amant immediately
Toronto currently brionyanddan geogebra
date okay your multi community committee
repeat official notice me magician a
Libra Hastinapura cannot it'll be fun of
my City fan electorate
let's go Rosco any more gear to stop me
mouth she was coming Marty everything to
me intentionally went out to impound
botanical heck Twista era specials were
that important era vilya in contaminate
adorned enemy rocket on Toros you know
no mantecato you monitor Mira personal
John to t-con cement across cement a
supportive avi rossabi equivalent
Elementary in tone about Tilden to be
killed security plastic etcetera
I think Otto Ventana the future coconut
Moon of Artemis England
hey yo no soy no pupillary maitake or
any premium yami-san CoA cancelled e
monotonic a nice you know POTUS entrare
normally go communica recognition of
omission or account okay
go Davos earlier requestable esta mi
sativum Joselito Montego Astana your
normal me Trinity aqua
[Music]
yester Tata molto bene sign inventing
over on me
omission Amaya mulatto the Meno prisoner
fedora
bring back my career started in okay
that was a bit a physical manner permit
cannot city come Eva been a professional
for beautiful token of Astana Miranda
from user value shown on Cora move to
Sheraton quill Aviva molto bene oculus
or our Moodle a Buddha listened Ocasek
mmm but make your page with you there's
really no difference between here and
home it's just everything's compacted
Daniel 14 by 14 room once you start
staffing your look out you're gonna be
working ten days on four days off late
June until usually mid-september it's a
pretty quiet existence this is my 24th
season there's a fire lookout and really
it's just you in the wind and the time
just melts away
my name is leif Hagen and we're at Toma
lookout a fire lookout is a structures
that sits on top of a mountain or ridge
top that has a good view of the
surrounding country and the staff are
then is tasked with living there for
extended periods to watch for fire it's
funny cuz I get a lot of questions about
the standard day you wake up with the
Sun I mean it's hard to sleep in a room
of glass much beyond sunrise first thing
I'll do is make a cup of coffee
and usually I have that first cup of
coffee on the front porch sit out there
watch the Sun come up
certainly every morning I go out for a
walk I check in at 10:00 hey good
morning I take the weather every day at
2:00 and check out at 4:15
[Music]
I think the solitary nature when there's
really no fire is going the only thing I
might do is check in on the radio twice
a day that might be the only time I
really talk unless I'm talking to myself
I think what's so tricky sometimes
talking about the lookout experience is
you're not talking to anybody about it
so you more intuitive you more
experience it I think that's why I was
used to term resonance because you just
can feel it and sense it
maybe that's fanciful but it certainly
is the way I feel about it you know you
just find yourself sitting on the porch
watching the world go by for hours on
end it's it's beautiful when you look at
you know lifestyle of a fire lookout it
can be a hard choice at times too you
know I'm missing a wedding tonight over
the course of summer you might miss a
lot of stuff in your life but certainly
every summer I keep coming back because
living on top of the mountain for days
on end it's just such a beautiful chance
at making a life of it
[Music]
[Applause]
we're four days walk from the nearest
road the landscapes vast the
wildernesses almost unlimited the access
is by aircraft on foot or on the right
day you can boat it but it's a challenge
in itself really we are at the mercy of
the weather and the tides and our day to
day life it's difficult living out here
but if you do what's needed and
everything comes together it's a really
rewarding place to be
[Music]
Warrick Mitchell lives in Fiordland New
Zealand's oldest and largest National
Park it covers over 12,000 square
kilometers but is home to only a few
dozen people the parks massive mountain
ranch isolates warwick from civilization
living out here like everywhere you need
shelter a good dry camp we have solar
panel for power lighting and satellite
communications we have a quad bike we
have two boats for fishing and diving
and we have the freezer which keeps our
food and our produce cold
we rely on rainwater for drinking water
so that's not too hard with 7 meters of
rainfall annually we largely live off
the land when you're living off the land
you really at the mercy of the weather
and the elements so there's certain
times that will allow you to go out and
harvest a deer or catch a fish capture
the menu
[Music]
if you have a down day and the waves are
really good you're more than likely
going to go surfing if the waves aren't
good but the rivers looking nice you
might catch a trout if the waves are
flat for the oceans come you might go
see fishing if the oceans stormy you
might go up the river for a kayak or go
through the bush and see if you can spot
a deer
living in the wilderness doesn't mean
you're living in isolation from people
we certainly couldn't be doing what we
do if it wasn't for the pilots and our
neighbors and our friends whether it's
the harshness of the environment and
being so isolated that brings people
together or the fact that the people
that are willing to travel this far have
like-minded passion for the environment
and the outdoors one thing's for sure
over the years is that the communities
become really tight-knit can you go
ahead and turn this main switch on and
we'll just see if she wants to work know
when things break or things don't go
your way it's always really important to
remember you're in the green the
experiences being out here and enjoying
being out here everything else is a
bonus so you can't get too serious if
one thing breaks I don't know too many
places in the world where you can stand
on a boat looking back and you can just
see ocean leading into forests leading
into massive snow-capped mountains in
Glacier shaped Bay's with pristine
rivers and clear water the trees are as
they were 200 years ago and the people
that I bring out here they get to
experience this nature as it was and as
it should be and we try to keep the area
and the environment pristine in this
little corner of New Zealand
[Music]
one officer goes to realize I got adult
career it is okay
Yoshiki yank a yo-yo a certain constant
a even el segundo come on whistle ahead
yes show me a ganado por que para ver
que cuando nombre concealed Cristo
enough eternal on yah minimus en la
venta Cinco de vacas - you know a
stracciatella think what they tell us
[Music]
your number sir imbecilic another in a
hobbit or uyama your mucho
nurse to the other I get the Tula so you
love another tenemos a salary per oculus
of clusters Tanguma t stereo castle
entrada ness a cupola
elliptical ro con una una scalinatella
will Marisa no kiribati another
into the world is a solution a chasm s
impossible a cattleman la cañada Lebanon
por que tiene Mucha bogus
well appearance academia desta catedral
cuando yo era washer or column on TV
that you know no shag on the July second
circle really really
Ariba gustaría dimensional and Estacada
you so important a mommy
[Music]
you